hi i'm christopher hine and today we're
going to be talking about more of the
fundamental theory of sword work so i'm
going to cover just a few other basic
concepts of sword work these are things
that often get glossed over and that no
one really tells you about and that's a
weird thing to say because these things
aren't like secrets but they're also
just so kind of trivial and boring in
lots of ways that i think people gloss
over them and if you don't understand
these trivial boring things you have a
real hard time understanding a lot of
the useful stuff that you would find in
sword work so i'm gonna call josh over
here and we're gonna talk about that
stuff today josh
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so let's talk about some some real
fundamental sword stuff and this stuff's
probably boring but it's so boring that
no one talks about it and these things
are truly essential skills because if
you don't understand these concepts
you're going to have a real hard time
with swordsmanship all right so first
let's i'm just going to have josh face
you and go into chew on ken kamai this
is chewed on ken kamai that's middle
sword position it's middle because his
sword's in the middle and that's opposed
to a jodon or a gate on right so those
are just the positions okay and ken
kamai just means sword stance so he's in
chewed on ken kamai which is middle
position with the sword
okay now
what he's trying to do with this
position is protect as much of his body
from the sword as possible all right so
understand that if josh is standing
perfectly centered so right now this is
kind of a at ease he's not he's not
super on guard right okay if the sword
if my sword or the attacker swords on
this side and it comes down it's hitting
in here and that goes into his body okay
if the sword is right here and it's
coming in it's hitting his body so when
josh truly blades his stance out right
so there he's truly bleeding his stance
out now if the sword's on this side
essentially and i understand there's a
suba right here so it can't go to his
hands his whole body is getting missed
by the other sword so that's why and let
me have a come over here and face me
that's why when we're sword to sword
like this we're hiding our bodies behind
our sword okay now if his sword were to
go the other side of this
i would have to move my body to the
other side of this right now the reason
for that is if anything's poking out
right here and he's got a quick action
he can come in and get me so what i'm
trying to do is protect myself from
those quick actions so that's what the
hanumi stance is doing it's blading me
to his actions that way i'm protected
from that sword making a super quick
action this is more and more dangerous
the closer we are so meaning a lot of
times when people at the foot
one foot distance
you'll see this where we can kind of be
in the middle and this is more
comfortable and it's more mechanically
advantageous but as people get closer
and closer with the swords you see this
starting to happen because they're
blading themselves and hiding behind
their sword now he's got to move his
sword over here first and when he does
that i have the chance to move myself to
the other side as well so understanding
why stance is happening is really really
important so this is kind of a neutral
stance right this is a truly bladed
stance and that's where i want to keep
his sword always on that side and a lot
of times i tell my students especially
my younger students it's like a dog and
a fence right so if we're here like this
the sword is my fence and the bad dog's
over there if the dog were to jump the
fence or bare crawl underneath i'm going
to come over here to this other side
right so so whatever that dog does i
want to be on the opposite side of the
fence because that protects me from the
dog's quick actions right so that's the
first thing to understand about honmey
and why we stand like that it's a bladed
position where we're hiding ourselves
behind the sword from his sword in case
there's a quick action okay now that's
why we stand the way we stand you also
need to understand
why we make the shots that we make and
so this is this is going to be in two
parts the first part is we're going to
talk about high shots versus low shots
right so for i think for most people not
really understanding how weapons work
works they think an attack to the leg is
roughly as good as attack to the body is
roughly as good as attack to the head
it's roughly as good as attack to any
core part of the body and their primary
attack should always be done to the core
and you know if you took out someone's
leg well then they can't walk anymore so
that's a that's a great thing to do
right the problem with that is i'm
always at an angular disadvantage when i
go to a low target okay now the reason
this is is because of the arc my sword
prescribes right so i don't know if
that's the way it's subscribed anyway so
so the way my my the arc that my sword
moves on so as i move up
it will start to eventually get shorter
relative to josh and as i move down it
will get shorter relative josh let me
show you what i mean with josh so
actually just hold your sword to your
side
okay so here i am i'm touching josh
right now so i'm touching him i'm not
going to change me at all josh isn't
going to change it all now as i drop my
sword watch what happens i all of a
sudden can't touch him and that's
because i'm i'm making a circle
basically here right so this part of the
circle is curving away from josh so you
see i can't reach josh nearly as easily
now in a situation where we were sword
on sword if i choose to attack his legs
i always put myself in danger there's
not a way to angle myself out of here
because he's got such a reach advantage
that i can't counter the reach advantage
so choosing to just randomly attack the
leg is generally a bad attack now there
are exceptions to that and you do see in
the aikido forums where we have leg
attacks now those are generally in
situations where we're pushed in close
and being pushed in close is the reason
that we have to
make a low attack and let me show you
what i mean so if we were really really
close and let's say josh is sort of
flown over here and i'm going to make my
attack like this and my posture is wrong
just because i want to face the camera
still while i'm doing this but i've made
my attack here and of course i should be
this way but just to make this work out
okay so i'm here like this now i've made
my attack on josh i'm in the worst part
of my sword to attack so sure it'll hurt
josh but that's not an ideal attack if i
go here i'm now in the sharpest part of
my sword the best part of my sword the
best part of the lever which means i'm
more likely to go through his leg here
and stop him than i am here and because
of the closeness he could hit me anyway
so i don't have to worry about like
making an angular advantage or something
like that because we're already two heck
and close and so you actually see that
in the forums now there is one other uh
situation where this happens really
dominantly in the aikido forms and it's
inside the sense a second
kumi touch and i'm going to talk about
that when we get there
i've changed it because
i'm displeased with the way it came off
and and i'll explain when we get to that
why that is but leg attacks in nikita
are generally only done when we're close
quarters and that's because it works out
better because of the closeness of the
situation
so in general high attacks are better
than low attacks because when i attack
him up here if i reach him up here my
body's farther away than his reach and
so he can't get me right he can't get my
legs can't get my body and that's good
and then because we now understand how
the timings work out of course if he
leaned in i could lean out if he stepped
in i could step out but we get that
advantage through high line attacks
versus low line attacks so higher line
attacks are better than lower line
attacks because of that that arc we
prescribed now the second part of
attacking that you have to understand is
that attacking the hands is almost
always better than attacking the body
now that doesn't seem like it's very
sensible because it seems like well i
want to incapacitate the other guy so
hitting him in the head or in the throat
or in the core of the body or taking off
a shoulder or something that's going to
be a more effective shot the problem
with that is all of those shots always
endanger me
more so i'm in greater danger for doing
that so let me show you what i mean so
if i just pick a random angle so i
haven't really measured my angle out
really nice here and i attack josh josh
can always easily counter attack that
right okay now i could of course pull
myself out now if josh attacks my body
he'll miss and if josh texts my head
he'll miss i have a josh almost showed
you what i'm going to show you right now
but if he goes for my hands you see he
can still get my hands he can still
reach my hands even though i'm in
position to hit him and everything else
is protected but my hands my hands are
not protected now that actually goes all
the way back to here look no chance that
i'm going to hit josh and josh can take
out my hands so if he chooses a clever
angle whereas suba is protecting his
hands and he attacks just my hands he's
going to win now the reason he's going
to win is because it's not just like an
owie you've destroyed my ability to hold
my weapon once you've destroyed my
ability to hold my weapon can't hold a
weapon i can't attack you with the
weapon that's great even if he doesn't
manage to get through my hand enough to
make me stop holding it he'll get a
second shot and a third shot and a
fourth shot and eventually those are
going to add up so
very likely that his katana is going to
go right through my fingers and take out
my fingers on the first sweep because
that's a fast moving powerful blade and
these guys are little and easy to get
through and all he's got to do really is
take out these two fingers and my
ability to use my sword is going to be
just about zero even if i'm a tough
tough guy right so so i really really
need all five of these working ideally
but this one's real bad this one's real
bad if i lose these of course i can't
hold my sword anymore so
that's what what we're looking at when
we're looking at attacks is we always
want to
attack the most available target and
that's generally going to be the hands
so hand attacks are generally better
attacks than body attacks there's all
kinds of situations where we can skew
that we get into advanced swordsmanship
we'll talk about why those are and then
the little things we can play with which
are great but in general that's that's a
good rule so understand high line
attacks are better than low line attacks
and attacks to the nearest target which
is generally the hands are the best
attacks you can make and it's because it
preserves you the best in both of those
situations actually okay one more thing
we need to talk about is the strength of
the lever so if josh just holds his
sword out here for me
this is a lever right
because it's a stick he's holding so the
way our universe works that makes this a
lever he has right now now the lever has
advantages and disadvantages right one
of the disadvantages one of the
advantages is that this end will move
really fast now which gives it a lot of
power to cut through stuff and that's an
advantage we definitely want from this
lever but the trade-off is this has less
strength than this now this moves much
slower but has more strength now i'm
going to ask josh to be as strong as he
can i'm going to take my pinky finger
only and i'm going to try and pull his
sword off line so resist me full force
josh that's my pinky finger and he's
fighting as hard as he can and i can
move that off right and the reason i can
do that is because he's got a mechanical
disadvantage so both of his hands and
his whole body working against my pinky
i can still pull this off line he can't
do nothing i'm wiggling my pinky he
can't stop me with that right and that's
because he's at a mechanical
disadvantage now if i come down here i'm
gonna do the same thing
i can only hurt my pinky right so i'm
strong i can make him body move but i
couldn't make a sword move right so i i
can't do it because there's a lot more
strength here the lever is stronger here
than here now when our swords are
matched up this is really really
important so here we're equal my weak
part to his weak part
here we're equal my strong part to his
strong part here
i'm winning because josh's weak part is
to my strong part here josh is winning
because my weak parts to his strong part
right if you looked into
spanish swordsmanship like la verdad de
estresa they break the sword up into
fractions right so these fractions tell
us how strong the comparison is but you
don't need to get into all that just
understand that this is the weakest
point it can be moved off the line the
easiest and this is the strongest point
it can be moved off the least easily at
least easily
so understanding where the strong part
of the sword and the weak part of the
sword is is really important to
swordsmanship especially when we're
talking about dueling and how you're
going to defend and knock their sword
out of the way and dominate the line and
all this kind of stuff so these ideas
are absolutely core
and i really believe most people aren't
talking that much about them now now
that hema is kind of around so
historical european martial arts and
there's a lot of manuscripts that kind
of talk about these details you're
seeing more stuff like strong and weak
is talked about quite a bit more now
timings are talked about things like
that but but it's really important to
understand these really fundamental
things like i said they're kind of
boring high line attacks are better than
low line attacks what does that even
mean you know and people would argue
about that even though physically you
can
show quite easily how a high line
attacks better than a low line attack
but you need to understand these
principles if you're going to understand
what swordsmanship is and in general
just what fighting with some kind of
lever with someone else is i'm
christopher hine thanks for watching
[Music]
you